ils sont les aventuriers
d'un nouveau monde
où les lois de la physique
n'ont plus rien à voir avec celle que
nous connaissons
un monde invisible à l'oeil nu que même
les instruments les plus puissants
ne peuvent tout à fait percevoir
dont même les scientifiques bryant n'ont
pas percé les secrets
on ne peut l'explorer que dans des
conditions
extrême
ils évoluent dans un environnement
unique tenu à tout prix à l'écart du
monde
tout doit être parfaitement contrôlées
pour que leurs plongées dans
l'infiniment petit
se fasse sans danger
la moindre poussière la moindre
vibration pourrait tout faire basculer
dans l'inconnu
[Musique]